hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
okey thing I don't know
[Music]
we're gonna start off with a game called
slender lonely Hong don't know why you
need to cry so much we all got problems
pages spot on random places every time
the game gets loaded interesting so this
is based off of the original Slenderman
obviously but I have not played a
Slenderman type game in a long time so
this will be kind of a throwback because
this is literally this isn't like a
Slenderman kind of game it's
legitimately this is supposed to be a
slender my end game which hasn't existed
for quite a while you need a key to open
the door
really I'm locked in here is that what
I'm led to believe am I supposed to be
able to open this oh well that's hard to
see oh that's better
thank you for teaching me about the
kheema game oh wow this looks awesome
you know that reminds me I never did
beat the original Slender Man game
I always got close but I never actually
beat it I'm sorry hello
okay probably nothing I don't have
anything to worry about until later on
in the game anyway not that Slenderman
can't kill you in the beginning but I'm
pretty sure oh pretty sure it only
starts after you first pick up a page it
might have been prudent to scout around
the area before I pick that up hey you
know what maybe I won't open that door
maybe on oh you need a flashlight to go
down soon do I do i is that something
that I need I mean it'd be nice but uh I
don't know if Mead is the correct word
as reassuring as the crying is I'm going
to ignore it for the time being and try
to find myself a flash of light Oh huh I
saw that you are tricky to find in the
pitch-black darkness but I'm assuming
that once I get a flashlight it will be
just a little bit easier Oh
another key thank you for that god this
damn floor damn floor is a son of a
[ __ ] oh hey now it's feeling like old
times
alright then make your move buddy boo
are you gonna go what are you gonna do
where you at Slendy man or Slendy boy
okay well that didn't answer my question
of what the hell was that
oh hi is that a Slendy ooh how do we get
over there I need that key yes please
key for me thank you so glad that every
door is securely locked in this place I
feel safer already
let's just go downstairs there's six
more pages I've got a feeling I'm gonna
need all all pages to open that door
oh we was in here thank you
that's much better I appreciate that
oh good okay no sign of Slendy yet I
would have thought that I would have
heard him thumping his way downtown by
now he's practicing his didgeridoo whoo
okay all right
he's gotta be around here somewhere oh
good good for ya that's usually when
things are good hello hello huh what is
that I don't know what that is
I have no idea Oh help me sure will do
buddy boo five well this seems easier
than I thought it'd be there's not a
single sign of the Slendy salut okay
well you know I guess I'll never know
what's on the other side of that door
because I don't have enough key okay I
don't know if key
hi don't know what that thumb pitch is
all about but you stop that now what was
that wait whoa whoa you can't just be
making random noises on me you have to
have a reason behind it or else I'm
gonna start to think you're a son of a
[ __ ] can i stuff this in my pocket sick
reference me thanks me how many can I
stop that my but how many of you guys
remember yield references of your okay
well I got a key that's good
found one I'm gonna ignore that I think
I can safely say that that is a whole
lot of nothing and I'm not gonna concern
myself with it what is making this
infernal racket oh I assumed it would
stop when I open the door oh god you
it's just a radio really it's just the
radio it's just a goddamn radio oh okay
well I don't need to open that door
because I already know where it goes how
about this one
hey how's it going champ hey slugger
how you doing it there slender man is
there no slender man in this game hey
weird considering the name of the game
is something slender okay oh seven of
eight
usually this is the deadly time but not
now
I guess oh wait what ooh I hear that oh
okay maybe it was full on me for
assuming that it'd be the exact same
recipe as before oh my god that's
getting it that's getting faster um hey
there's no need wherever you are
Oh was i under a time limit this whole
time I'm gonna grab it I'm gonna grab it
then I'm gonna grab this and I'm gonna
get out there I've got eight what do I
do now that I am eight I've got another
key plenty man don't do this to me okay
it's fine I got eight so I just get out
right oh god wait what the hell what am
i how am i fine why was he in that
corner [ __ ] scuse me you got me hook
line and sinker E are you kidding me
you're gonna make a Slenderman game here
the only time he shows up it right at
the end he was afraid of me
I was the scary one and why there's
nothing scary about me oh well whatever
okay cool had great ambience there was
so much there so much potential and yet
they squandered it oh well whatever
moving on
all right so this next game is called
start survey um ah sure yeah let's do
this
whatever this is are you having a nice
day yeah it's been pretty good pretty
chill do you have many responsibilities
oh you know a few like I gotta you what
wait what wait a minute what why would
maybe I have to close my window what
Oh oops oh wait no that's not good
no I dropped something once I pick it up
oh wait I guess don't need this garbage
here
oh yeah the answer is yes sorry look
around for a moment oh okay yeah I will
are you familiar with your surroundings
oh yeah do you know where you are
oh well I mean now that you mention it
um uh no what have you ever had a panic
attack you know not really why do you
ask
maybe I don't think so do you find
yourself questioning your existence Oh
every day you know overall newness
honest we kind of do that on a daily
basis you know the whole channel ain't
gonna last long so you better go check
it out if you haven't already because
it's about to go away yes do you believe
there is a God oh you know that's a
pretty that's pretty heavy question uh
me personally no not really
uh-uh so I'm gonna go with a no are you
answering these questions out of free
will you know I was thinking uh maybe he
I just like could have been by it was
hoping yes
are you certain when you put it like
that you know I'm not a hundred I'm so
paranoid right now I'm so paranoid why
see what are you gonna do to me yeah
yeah do you feel comfortable in your
room yeah yes so comfortable I'm gonna
go with the big no on that one
if the lights went out would you be
scared ah
I'm brave
who's that I can't I won't tell you Oh
God never wondered when you'll die
thought about it thought about it you
know this black and white aesthetic is
very good at very honest honesty I love
it oh that's a problem um that no okay
have you cleaned off your desk lately
yeah yeah actually yeah I have
I did actually open the folder on your
desk
that's a little weird that you know that
okay
oh I know that you recognize contents of
the folder yeah that's a di Megara fault
yes
throw away the contents of the folder
you have internet access
oh my go yeah do you have any enemies
you know I'm a pretty nice guy but you
know you gotta make a break a few eggs
if you want to get to the top if you
suddenly went missing would anybody come
looking for you probably I'm gonna go
with the big illa yes on that one
because I think everybody watching this
video might suspect something
are you alone define alone are any of us
really alone on this world right now
yeah and this room I really hope so yeah
if you screamed would anybody here Bobby
technically in the recording people
might in the future you're asking some
really probing questions here I don't
feel comfortable with this uh yeah I'm
gonna go with you do you know the person
standing behind you I pull that trick
you don't pull it you don't pull that
trick on me is there anybody behind me
you guys who tell me right if there's
someone by me right you guys would tell
me hos there I didn't even think about
in the game
yes I implode relax take some time to
relax okay we okay relaxing time for a
relaxing people oh so chill I'm chill as
can be are your feelings real and not
just programmed like a machine yeah
they're real and valid is there a
meaning to life sure probably do you
know who you are yet
markiplier [ __ ] who do you think you
are you think you know who I am I knew
who I am I'm a man whose five ovens do
you know what is happening
oh never nah know why not really if you
were told the truth about your existence
would you deny it in hopes for a better
answer no I'd probably accept it
hahahaha yeah hey what's up they ask you
questions is it really you answering oh
you know yeah probably I think yeah if I
could prove to you that you are not
sentient would you be shocked sure yeah
sure you want to know the truth all
right
I love truth look out your window okay I
did it but nothing look okay oh look
around you it's from the door of the
house next door ah oh
101 Oh
[Music]
Oh where's Eric go poo poo poo goodbye
you for what it is and now I finally
done it
I can finally set you free okay I'm free
please avoid the frizz can be glad we
had that conversation thank you for
letting me know that I am now free big
preach on that okay good I'm gonna go
question my existence
I'm gonna go question everything I've
ever done I'm gonna get I will go over
there and I'm gonna be like who i cuz i
don't know what's happened anymore with
my life
Who am I I don't remember okay this one
is called it lies Oh weird hello are you
my pop am i the monster oh no if oh if
you I swear do anything to that dog
[Music]
come on
this is amazing but I don't know what's
happening huh Freya huh just ready new
well what's happening my eyes
[Music]
Oh
I'm not sure what lies but something is
lying right now and it better not be
about my dog okay how do I play woz
shift here we need to break free from
grasp I don't know what's gonna be
grabbing me but it better not be
grabbing me too severely because I'm
gonna have a severe problem with that so
uh might want to think twice all right
let's uh let's go for it baby let's do
this whatever this is am I trying to
find my dog or something okay it's real
quiet
Oh after two distant encounters we've
failed to locate the gentles and we have
no comparison to determine sex suggests
the creature reproduces asexually and
less likely that it's only the only one
of its kind I'm sorry I didn't know I
would find a research paper nailed do a
windmill just seems like something that
you know I wouldn't ordinarily encounter
what am I doing here hey bucket head oh
this is normal what is happening hey hey
oh
exposed bone covers its skull at this
time we're unsure if it's natural or if
it's another example the creature
grafting organic material to itself like
it did with the wheat another plant
matter its body surprisingly human-like
but deformed and elongated a single tail
snakes okay well someone was killed in
the middle of writing this message and I
don't know why I'm not taking that as a
warning doesn't spend so much time
reading it I'm just confused we
originally thought the purpose of the
creatures unparalleled ability to mimic
voices was to lure creatures closer to
ambush and while this may be true to an
extent we've noticed the creature
exhibits sadistic behaviors it seems to
toy with its prey using their own voices
or voices of previous victims of dormant
the subject oh hi truck car ooh the
Jabberwocky well ain't that a handsome
thing okay alright then I don't know
what I'm supposed to do with this sudden
influx of information about a
Jabberwocky the creature attracts seemed
to vary oftentimes displaying bipedal
patterns with prints similar to
elongated human hands we imagine this is
how its prints
other times the tracks trail revealing a
pattern similar to that of a snake and
I'm just
supposedly finding these in some
semblance of an order or am I really
haphazardly wandering through the forest
here because I would like some direction
but it seems like I'm making it okay oh
I did that
Oh
so this is what I was doing hello Oh
hop-hop wait no come back oh damn it up
don't run from me hop where are you
going
whoa Oh what the hell what what's going
on what what what are you doing
I can't run that fast oh oh I see
okay well I yeah that's fine I read this
one did I need to do anything - I heard
that all the way over here okay yeah
well I knew about this I already knew
where oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no oh
that's not good oh that's a bad thing
oh that's a hole in the ground that's a
jabberwocky sized hole in the ground Oh
Oh No
yeah what do you see what do you see boy
okay I guess I read these out of order
what what why why why whoa whoa whoa
whoa Wow Wow that's much bigger than I
thought it was gonna be oh my god oh do
I do anything about it that I just do I
oh my god
I heard that
poppers knob up herb up oh oh they're
here okay okay
hi oh oh my god what if what what dog
dog up oh wait what I don't know what
happened
han I have to go back in the game just
because I have to see like what just
happened okay so I what I think happened
is I was supposed to find these in the
order that the dog shows you but because
I wandered around and saw everything
first it like flagged that I saw
everything and then probably just ended
the game I don't know why that's how it
ends the game but that's what it did so
I just gotta follow what was that did I
just see in the world
did I just see that did I see what I
think I saw I saw a tail this makes a
lot of sense
this explains why I was so confused well
wha
see now I'm getting all the things I was
supposed to be getting before and I
wasn't able to get oh yeah the whole
that's problem
whoa whoa what what what okay see now
this makes a lot of sense now this makes
a lot of sense hello hello al oh oh well
I guess it's go time
apparently no don't take me I don't
wanna go no no don't take me I gotta get
outta here
listen I gotta go
well I'm dead I got it oh it does lie it
lies I'm guessing it lies means like it
also calls as the barking dog sometimes
okay anyway that is three scary games
got some good ones this time around not
too shabby I don't like it a lot so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more scary games why
not leave a tasty delicious like right
down there subscribe to be notified of
when new videos are coming at you hot
and heavy ring the bell to know exactly
one thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]